the United States will withdraw from the
Paris climate Accord President Trump
made that announcement one year ago
today former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg is working to bypass the
president's opposition to the Paris
climate agreement
Loum Berg is launching a new effort this
morning to help the u.s. achieve the
goals adopted by the Obama
administration the centerpiece is a
seventy million dollar American cities
climate challenge the program will
select 20 US cities and help them speed
up their efforts to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions the program aims to push
the u.s. toward the Paris pledge to cut
greenhouse gases by 26% from 2005 levels
by 2025 that's seven years from now
Bloomberg's best-selling book climate of
Hope co-authored by Karl Pope is now
available in paper book and we're
pleased to have Michael Bloomberg here
good to have you so how does this
program help cities try and tackle
climate change
well cities aware the people live
seventy percent of the people live in
cities are getting close to that if you
use energy in the city even if pollution
comes from the power plant if you'd cut
back your energy use in the cities
wherever the power plant is would cut
back its pollutants what's happening in
the world is very worrisome nobody knows
where it goes scientists have theories
about it but the direction is horrendous
it was a hundred and twenty two point
four degrees in Pakistan two weeks ago
it was over freezing on the North Pole
17 out of the 18 warmest years on record
have been since the year 2001 something
is going on and it just makes no sense
to continue in the direction we're going
we should take prophylactic actions now
cut back greenhouse gases increase the
fuel efficiency of cars and things like
that regenerate solar and wind power
which is cheaper now than fossil fuel
power it's good economics it creates
jobs and it protects us of what might
happen down the road I've noticed you're
making this announcement on the one-year
anniversary of the president's decision
to withdraw from the Paris climate a
change there are some experts that say
that his decision has actually spurred
more
I'm a change like a backlash well I've
joked a little bit about it but it is
easier to raise money for sensible gun
regulations and the background checks
and for climate change things because
he's come out and I've joked that I want
him to do more actually my great hope is
that the president will take a look at
his he's been getting bad advice and
he'll change his mind and we've watched
him he can change his mind changes it
frequently hopefully he'll come around
and do something that makes some sense
not doing anything about climate change
really just makes no sense whatsoever
and it jeopardizes all of us not only
for the long term but your children have
a greater risk of having an asthma
attack your CH you have a greater risk
of getting stomach cancer if the air and
the water isn't clean so if you don't
worry about the future just worry about
you and your family today and you'd do
the same thing mr. mayor is there a way
to go around obstacles like this in
Washington is this a template for well
first on the climate change question is
there a way to go around Washington as
you're trying to or does there have to
be some action well the federal
government doesn't have a lot to do with
climate change John really it is
President Obama to get a law passed
Donald Trump said he stopped the law he
didn't it's been tied up in the courts
and never put into place so the federal
government's not involved the state
government's only a little it's city
governments and the private sector
mostly the private sector if you stop if
you turn off your air conditioner before
you leave in the morning if you better
more fuel-efficient car if you switch to
LED and complex 4s and light bulbs you
will do something talk to corporations
corporations are under big pressure from
their employees their customers but
mainly their investors to do something
let me and so they're trying to be more
climate-friendly as a former mayor let
me ask you the politics about this as a
mayor I think of potholes and keeping
the snow off the roads because I grew up
in the East Coast potholes are bad to
city but what constituents would say
stop worrying about the temperatures in
Pakistan fix things here so how do the
politics work the politics are 80 or 90
percent of the public thinks climate
change is real and thinks we should do
something about it and even in Congress
where it used to be a commie plot this
climate change stuff now they say well
it's happening but it's not man-made you
can measure what goes into the air you
can measure when you have dirt
year what happens and so this you stop
and think of what the Secretary of
Energy of environmental protection crew
it's saying this is craziness if there's
any possibility of the end of the world
happening you should take action even if
you think it's negligible it doesn't
matter
it's the consequences are so bad it's
just irrational to not continue to do
some of these things of reducing climate
change factors and even for example the
President or Pruitt I guess it was said
that they want to rollback the
requirements for automobiles to be more
fuel efficient pollute less automobile
companies don't want you to roll it back
the president floored yesterday said no
we like this regulation it's a new world
we should be more environmentally
friendly or we're not gonna have a
business down the road this is the
automakers being required to double
their fuel economy standards for now
more than 50 miles a gallon to 2025 and
as you said the automakers say yes and
now it's the president well it's been
partially if they don't do it other
companies around the world are going to
do it from a competitive point of view
everybody wants more fuel-efficient
stuff now I can't tell you everybody
does everything perfectly every day but
people are worried when they see things
happening and and and to not take
appropriate preventive actions which
generally don't hurt anybody don't cost
any money
most of the stuff if you switch for
example from coal to natural gas you
save a lot of money if you switch from
natural gas to solar and wind you save a
lot more money so the coal-fired power
plants want to move and so far it's
something like 268 coal-fired power
plants have announced that they're
closing out of 530 and that's brought
down greenhouse gases a lot in America
mr. mayor everybody knows you have a lot
of money and you like to do it to use
good I loved your opening letter to
Bloomberg philanthropies where you said
in god we trust' everybody else bring
data and what is the data showing you
about education because you're also
putting a lot of money to education
three hundred and seventy five million
dollars you announced yesterday to do
what Gail this is he education is going
to be more and more important as the
world changes as social media and
technology influences our lives if you
don't have a good education you have a
very small chance of being wealthy and
being comfortable and being able to just
ate it and make ends meet are all levels
of the economic spectrum so in less than
30 seconds what do you want to do you
want to improve the school system our
school systems have been going down
compared to the rest of the world China
is improving their schools they are the
most environmentally friendly country
they're going to all electric cars as
their objective they're moving fuel
coal-fired powerplants away and doing
everything we're going in the other
direction and the president says he's
worried about competition with China so
am i they have a five and ten year plan
we have a plan our economic plan is the
next temporary budget cycle three months
mr. Bloomberg Mayor Michael Bloomberg we
miss you always good to have you at the
table the paper book edition of climate
of hope is on sale wherever you like to
buy your books